matter hard she was arguably better
known for the work she did lying down
rather than standing up the French
wanted her to become a spy here was a
woman who had extremely intimate access
to Europe's high and mighty many of whom
came from the military or politics and
so Mata Hari became a French intelligent
asset she was thrown in right at the
deep end too the idea was that she would
catch him in a Honey Trap before taking
him somewhere private and vigorously
pumping him for
information if successful she will be
paid 1 million Franks as the FRS
believed Little Willie was a senior
General with access to all kinds of
secrets that could help swing the war in
their favor not long after the French
enlisted her as a sex spy she met German
Consul in the Netherlands it's widely
believed the German suspected matahari
was working for the French and she was
arrested and sentenced to
death